the theory of toxic masculinity was once
relegated to academic settings workshops
and and feminist symposia but now that
mindset has infected almost every area
of our culture our businesses our
schools and now of course our politics
dismissing and even demonizing the
contributions of men throughout our
history has become oh so inspiring
or at least Elizabeth Warren thinks so I
wanted to give this speech right here
and not because of the arch behind me or
the president that this square is named
for nope we're not here today because of
famous arches or famous men because of
some hardworking women
well her comments kind of tossing off
involvement of men in our society it
speaks volumes about the direction the
Democrats will take if they gain control
again
so men who are heterosexual strong
aggressive competitors are no longer an
acceptable part of society not really
there the problem after all the
professionals have told us so
last year the American Psychological
Association released guidelines for
psychological practice with boys and men
that trashed traditional masculinity as
leading to quote aggression and violence
as a means to resolve interpersonal
conflict as well as substance abuse
incarceration and early mortality well
of course for years Hollywood's been
pushing the skinny jeans crop top pajama
boy version of masculinity on us we've
gotten kind of used to it and now even
time-honored mail brands and businesses
are trying to make men feel guilty about
being men bullying the meter movement
against Sagittarius masculinity
is this the best a man can get
[Music]
is it
it's been going on far too long
we can laugh at all well not all boys
thankfully it will be bullies but you'd
almost think so
after watching ads like that and it used
to be that only the fringe eeeh stub the
fringe feminists believe that
traditional family structures were
inherently oppressive and dangerous of
course with men head of the household in
some cases being the main culprits but
now the entire Democratic Party is
captive to this anti male outlook if you
were a young man who grew up pre woke
nests if you're a member of an all-male
club or fraternity or if you played a
sport especially one like I don't know
football or lacrosse you're immediately
suspect it doesn't matter how well you
lived your personal life or how much you
achieved in your professional life your
very existence is a threat to this new
order now we all just saw what the left
did again or tried to to Supreme Court
justice Brett Kavanaugh people who live
in Washington know what the culture was
like in Georgetown Prep at least then
the memories they will be testifying to
were memories recorded in the brains of
drunk teenage boys he was drunk
allegedly in every one of these
incidents frat boy culture is not
literally on trial nor is it illegal and
and yes there may be questions of candor
I think frat boy culture is on trial
here mmm but defaming Cavanagh of course
is a predator that was just another way
of claiming Trump as one which Democrats
think will help them with women voters
big think they can ride the me to wave
right into the White House but they have
to think women are very very stupid
if you're a male Democrat politician
you're forced to defer to the gender
warriors and apologize for your sex I
think we would look for somebody who is
maybe not of the same gender that I am
and maybe somebody might be a couple of
years younger than me I will have a
woman running mate to me it's really
clear that we do that it would be very
difficult not to select a woman with so
many extraordinary women who are running
right now okay well maybe woman would be
the best person to pick on the basis of
merit but since when did sexual organs
alone become a qualification for high
office stunning which led me to wonder
can princess spitting ball or Camilla
Harris pick a male running mate or will
that make them part of the patriarchy as
well huh MSNBC's Joy Reid took the anti
male narrative a step further adding
racial and religious elements to it and
when you have a very determined minority
in this case wealthy white men and
wealthy white Christian men and
Christian Americans who are fundament of
the fundamentals' variety who are very
clear that no matter what happens if
they have to pull the South Africa model
to maintain power forever they will do
it and they're not afraid of it and
they're increasingly open about it and
Donald Trump is merely the avatar for
this their increasingly open about it I
must have missed all of that and by the
way I have to say this when they attack
our founders are kind of dismissed them
this is where they're going the entire
American experiment they believed was
sinful and awful because it was started
by conquest white men with their
traditional notions of work and morality
subjugated women and other minorities
end of story
nothing really good came after that thus
the thinking goes it's the duty of all
secular leftists to marginalize and
hobble men who obstruct their vision of
revolutionary change political and
otherwise
now think of where that leaves us as a
society this entire mindset and as a
country with our men either neutered or
perpetually in a defensive posture
dismissive or angry in
now that's toxic if you prefer in
America run by a bunch of gender
enlightened bullies that by all means
vote Democrat that's gonna be fun and
that's the angle